hello everyone my name is harini
balasubramanian and i'm a research
fellow at pine biotech today i will be
presenting my project titled in silico
comparative transcriptomic analysis of
endemic and epidemic kubose sarcoma
this project was mentored by dr
raghavendran lakshmi narayan
before i begin into
the details about my project i would
like to tell you a little bit about
myself
so
my uh
i have a bachelor's degree in industrial
biotechnology from anna university india
my research interests predominantly lie
in
molecular biology so some example areas
are micro rna profile analysis
toxicogenomics precision medicine cancer
biology and methylation epigenetics
i aspired to pursue my master's degree
in molecular and cellular biology
so
what is capocity sarcoma
kaposi sarcoma is an anti-proliferative
multicentric malignancy that is
triggered by the infection of kshv or
kaposi sarcoma associated herpes virus
it has four distinct clinical subtypes
first epidemic ks which is an aggressive
subtype that is commonly occurring in
hiv zero positive individuals second
the classic chaos which is found in
older men of eastern european descent
third in the michaels which is prevalent
in certain areas of equatorial or
sub-saharan africa
and lastly
transplant-related ks which occurs when
an immunosuppressed transplant patient
is also infected with kshp
so kshv is an oncogenic human gamma
herpes virus
which is also the etiological agent that
is responsible for not only kaposi
sarcoma but also strongly associated
with b-cell proliferative disorders
including primary effusion lymphoma
the variant binds to the cell surface
receptor following which the viral dna
migrates into the nucleus
kshv exists between a lytic and latent
life cycle upon infection kshv
establishes a long-term persistent
infection in humans where it manipulates
multiple host signaling pathways and
also modulates the expression of
cellular genes to thrive in the infected
cells
in general kshv infection is essential
but not adequate to induce ks disease
progression
despite antiretroviral treatment the
prognosis for ks is often poor with high
mortality due to the presentation of
late cancer stage
therefore
to identify more accurate detection
methods and therapeutic targets against
ks a better understanding of the viral
and trans and cellular transcriptomes in
the cancer are necessary
so
this is the information about the data
set that i obtained for my analysis the
data was downloaded from the nc ncbi geo
platform in raw rate counts
the study involved a total of 51 samples
of which three samples of normal skin
were taken from three healthy
individuals and the rest from ks
patients
here the samples from the diseased
individuals were obtained in pairs that
is the biopsies from lesional skin and
uninvolved sites on the same individual
were collected
raw cons for each chain from the human
and kshv transcriptomes were provided by
the authors
this is the methodology and the
flowchart that i followed for the for my
analysis
uh firstly i group the samples into
endemic care samples epidemic and normal
skin
secondly uh exploratory analysis or
principal component analysis here was
conducted using the the following
parameters
pca was conducted first for all the
samples and then for endemic and
epidemic separately
next differential expression analysis
using the desector algorithm and the
enrichment and gse modules were also
performed
to understand the upregulated and
downregulated genes
and these were the parameters that were
used for the analysis
and lastly human gage analysis for a
better understanding of the pathways was
also performed using the parameters as
given on the flow chart
these are the results of the pca
pipeline
and
this is the result for the
uh differential expression and human
gene uh human gauge results so
um for epidemic ks and endemic ks uh dot
plots for geoengi pathways
seen at plots also for enriched pathways
volcano plots uh they were all obtained
and uh for epidemic case alone the
arachidonic acid pathway and retinol
metabolism were significantly
downregulated
similarly for endemic ks
the human gauge results showed that the
ribosome pathway was also significantly
suppressed
now moving on to the biological
interpretation part of the results that
we've obtained from our pipelines
so a majorly upregulated gene in endemic
ks was sox11 so sox11 is a neural
transcription factors which is highly
expressed in mesenchymal and neural
progenitor cells
it is also considered an oncogene
because of its ability to induce
tumorogenesis by promoting cell survival
so the increased transcript level of
this gene can be implicated
in
can be implicated in
the progression of the cancer and it can
be an important biomarker of capocity
sarcoma provide
sorry provided that the detection assay
is also coupled with certain viral genes
and
in endemic in epidemic ks the orf6 viral
gene was most upregulated and this was
restricted only to epidemic years
it is a gene that is activated during
early lighting replication phase in
age-related ks
so co-infection with hiv in aids rated
ks
accelerates and aggravates
chaos development so it is possible that
the high levels of the gene product were
also a result of the indirect role of
hiv in disease propagation
next let's move on to the results of the
volcano plot for epidemic years
so ppf ppe f1 and pcdh17
along with cemip
were found to be massively upregulated
so ppef1
is significantly correlated with retinal
degeneration and pcdh17 and cemip were
found to uh have positive
correlations with cell to cell
connection and epithelial mesenchymal
transition pathways
so the over expression of these genes in
uh
epidemic is patients is indicative of
sarcoma progression
next let's look at the volcano plot for
endemic ks
so first uh
if we see the uh
s100 a1 gene
it plays an important role in inhibition
of microtubule assembly so its increased
transcription level can be implicated in
promoting cell proliferation and
migration like the pc
sk16 and thereby the metastasis of
cancer cancer tissues
moving on to the pathways
the lipid metabolism and energy the
energy generation pathways
were significantly downregulated in
epidemic years
the lack of regulation in lipid
metabolism was observed in both
subtypes
but the transcriptional imbalance was
more pronounced in
epidemic yes
and this can be seen in the arachidonic
acid pathway as i mentioned earlier
the arachidonic acid is a multifaceted
pufa molecule that uh confers cell
permeability that confirms permeability
to the cell membrane and also produces
uh is also involved in producing
prostaglandins and leukotrienes
so ara or arachidonic acid oxidation
produces many other crucial molecules
that participate in wound healing energy
balance and response to pathogen
invasion
so the suppression of this pathway in
epidemic es can be implicated in the
reduced immune response and dysfunction
of the central nervous system
next
another down regulated pathway in
epidemic ks was the retinol metabolism
pathway
so retinas are known to inhibit
uncontrolled cell growth and
the the suppression of this pathway
substantiates the significant anti-tumor
efficacy of the current use of retinoids
in treating localized skin lesions
and lastly the ribosomal proteins
pathway uh was
suppressed in the endemic case
samples
so
this may be connected to the recent
fascinating discovery that kshv induces
production of the specific ribosomes
that are preferential for viral lactic
phase mrnas so it's possible that the
virus manipulates the cell machinery to
suppress the organically produced
ribosomes in favor of the ribosomal
proteins that aid in viral lytic protein
production
in conclusion
six genes in endemic years and epidemic
yes were identified respectively to be
differentially expressed in these
disease conditions
while the incidence of endemic ks is
decreasing in developed countries like
the usa it is still very prevalent in
sub-saharan africa and the mediterranean
so
till date the detection of lana or
the orf-1 gene product is the golden
standard for kshv diagnostics in this
study too orf73 gene uh which encodes
for lana um
was found to be well upregulated in both
conditions with similar fall change
values
but how far a lana-based assay can
characterize the extent of case
progression is not clear
so from our from this study uh two two
potential biomarkers have been
identified one orf6 and two sox11
uh orf6
uh could be a potential biomarker for
detecting co-infection in kshv in
hiv-positive individuals
and sox-11 since it's heavily involved
in propagating lesions and triggering
angiogenesis makes it another uh
prospective biomarker for ks
so in conclusion more research on the
physiological and genotypic presentation
of capocity sarcoma is highly essential
to discover more therapeutic targets
that can increase not only the longevity
but also the quality of life in people
living with hiv and in ks patients
these are the references that i used
thank you so much